have you ever tried to do something and
it just doesn't work out the way you
want it of course maybe two but there's
also a subreddit for that relatable oh
my god this is very relatable to me
there was an attempt there was an
attempt to operate pizza correctly I
ordered one large pizza and when it came
I don't know if it was a joke
but literally nothing on it just the
crust no sauce cheese toppings
nothing Pizza Hut Jessie we would like
to hear more about this order please
contact us Jessie response
my bad fam I was high as Frick and
opened the pizza upside-down what we're
a pizza how do you open it ah God
you know what cringe I would never open
a pizza upside-down there was an attempt
to use facial recognition
- doorbell automatically locks the front
door when it sees a face it doesn't
recognize today it didn't recognize me
so I went into the app and investigated
and it's Batman stop trying to break
into my house Batman not today Batman
that's hilarious there was an attempt to
type a problem content Jedi what is this
what country is this oh wow
[Music]
why is that so funny hey hey just like
do something in front of the computer
just like type look look natural okay
swimming in front of the keyboard maybe
she's doing something that makes
perfectly sense massaging the keyboard
everyone does that there was an attempt
to visualize Internet addiction which
addiction is yours
Instagram Photoshop linked in uber god I
just freaking love her so much
I cannot stop ever they're driving to
the nearest bus stop and calling another
ubers my strange addiction ordering
ubers for no reason I mean I see what
they mean though it's like it's so
convenient to get an uber so instead of
I don't know getting a bus but then
again who cares I don't know there was
an attempt to choose a female CEO Oh
The Washington Post post this headline
ubers search for a female CEO has been
narrowed down to three men Wow what
darah that's a female named cool they
did it it's a compensation they did it
congratulations there was an attempt
this is gonna be good to virt your
signal notice anything about this at
Huffington Post editors meeting okay
y'all don't hire black people lol oh god
Karen oh na oh God there was an attempt
to cry sexism
what is this subreddit everyone Google
search actor and count how many men come
up before one freaking woman holy crap
hahahahaha
well maybe if you type the word actress
there's no men showing up when I type
firewoman as a search where all the men
this is so sexist oh my god there was an
attempt to explain who Barack Obama is
oh my god are we finally gonna find out
his last name epic Barack Obama Michelle
Obama's husband okay I understand that
guy of course who is Barack Obama again
I forgot
it's Michelle Obama's husband of course
now it all makes sense
Barack Obama's last name is Michelle
Obama's husband now it makes sense there
was an attempt to protest homophobia
Arianna saying Frick it to the
homophobic owner of Coachella and
showing the LGBT flag is the energy we
need in 2019 our H Ella she totally
owned him by headlining and making him a
lot of money damn Ariana you sure showed
him us this is such a perfect example of
virtue signaling like you're not
changing anything there was an attempt
to correct the students answer okay
teachers be dumb question mark it took
Mary ten minutes to saw a board in the
two pieces if she works just as fast how
long will it take for take her to saw
another board into three pieces with
twenty yeah twenty minutes no answer is
fifteen it kills 10 equals two and 15
equals three and twenty equals four
what a dummy damn that was an attempt to
be anti-government when you're so
anti-government that you pay extra money
to the government to show the government
you don't support them
I used the government to destroy the
government it's the same thing is this
the whole subreddit people doing things
yeah people doing things good
description there was an attempt to take
a panoramic photo which included their
dog Oh God
oh my god
what is that I want to try that it's
hilarious
it's beautiful my good there was an
attempt to make an infographic okay each
dot represents five thousand hot dogs
damn what is that why are there that
many hot dogs in this areas each dot
represents five thousand untapped
infinite hog supply outside of the
United States Wow it looks like America
is about to get invaded by hot dogs
wait each state is lined with whoa we're
trapped
yeah maybe you some hot dogs colors in
there this info grant that's hilarious
we lost Canada and fixin to hogs already
there was an attempt to roast males good
luck there's nothing to roast about why
males to take so long to mature y'all
dumb or something why females take so
long to get ready y'all ugly or
something
why does every red it feel like I'm
gonna get in trouble I don't know about
these anymore
stop please there was an attempt to ask
about dirty toilets what is the worst
state you've seen a public bathroom in
New Jersey no that's not what I meant
Kansas Tennessee Louisiana there was an
attempt to showcase women in the STEM
fields Oh Oh God here put on the glasses
that'll make you look professional
now be careful not to burn your frickin
hand up what is STEM fields
that's a soldiering iron Aaron [ __ ] this
gets hot super hot there was an attempt
to make a smoothie oh god wait is it
stuck in the ceiling oh that's my
nightmare god Tammis awful there was an
attempt to be genderless the MTV Awards
are completely genderless so there's no
separation when it comes to Talent also
we are thrilled that four out of five
nominees in the next category are
it's literally I'm not supposed to say
my opinion but this is really great also
there was an attempt to tell a dark back
joke not not yo no that's not how it
goes you have to say who's there let's
try this again
knock-knock ha ha ha ha ok who's there
honeydew law anyway what yeah there was
an attempt to speak English good good li
if you don't know the difference between
there and there and they are you heard
idiot well this is awkward
I feel like this is a troll this has to
be a troll ok I got a joke for you
there was an attempt to tell a
knock-knock joke again ok ok I got a
joke for you kid knock-knock
come in hey what's up I have a nest cam
so I can see you it's fine there was an
attempt to get information from an
anti-vaxxer oh I'm just trying to
understand why would the government lie
about such a thing just wondering
control please elaborate now well you'd
sure change my mind thank you very much
bombs against vaccines
I can't believe it's a thing blows on my
mind there was an attempt to make
someone feel guilty you just caused a
suicide how do you feel
you're literally still talking to me I'm
doing it now how should I do it
hi this is Ronnie's dad do you know
Ronnie nope he's dead my baby is dead so
you found your son dead and jumped on
his xbox how do you feel
Oh God no I better check his xbox hi do
you know this person he's dead I better
go to my son's xbox friendless there was
an attempt to be secure answer of
security questions hello pizza cat lover
just one more step please answer these
security questions what's your favorite
food and what's your favorite animal if
you can answer these we give the
password to anyone thank you oh my god
that's hilarious there was an attempt to
advertise plus-sized clothing
while we guys well done whoever thought
of this a plus okay so that's how they
look like on this game that's so dumb
Jesus Christ they actually did that
there was an attempt to prove
vaccinations don't work okay again let's
not forget about anti-vaxxers yeah there
has been multiple scientific studies on
the dangers of vaccinations
show me one please government controls
the internet now so I can't find what
I'm looking for how do people get so
delusional thanks for trying
it must be on the second page of Google
or Google or something no one's ever
gonna find it it's practically in the
void there was an attempt to take a
regular passport photos oh yes throwback
to the time my grandma got confused
getting passport photos taken and joking
oh it's funny because I've literally
done the same thing I've seen when you
pick Oh flash bless her she kept the
photo too imagine just showing that for
your password proto oh wow you playing
Liverpool that's epic come right through
there was an attempt at getting a
portrait found on Facebook market the
artist was very serious about their work
was the artist on drugs Jesus Christ did
she draw nipples the map and also like
she has kind of a goofy words called for
head how do you there was an attempt to
be comfortable so my mom accidentally
ordered an extra small dog bed but he's
still so grateful that is the cutest
thing I have ever seen in my entire life
there was an attempt to put on a face
mask
oh my god how please stop Oh God people
where the world attire Japan I'm gonna
pull out with that see what kind of
faces I get that was an attempt to
encourage people to give blood don't
save a life be afraid to give blood be
afraid
oh god I love these just hit just right
it normally stop trying to be quirky and
use different sizes and ways to read it
Jesus Christ don't be afraid be very
afraid I was about to do it when this
sign just turned me off that was an
attempt to write down the right
information installed on the ceiling why
write the date oh really that's amazing
well this subreddit has certainly made
me understand just how stupid people are
absolutely amazing
I have newfound respect in people's
ineptitude thank you so much there was
an attempt now I actually feel like I'm
super smart I need to read more letters
like this hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you want more reddit videos
link to it here in the outro and see you
gamers next time like by the merch
epicly probably the last time I'm ever
gonna say it that's a lie bye bye well
you haven't tried to pursue malade
accessory after 50 million outros much
now just now it's still relevant just
download it